according to the imperial college
researchers 96
000 people a day in england are being
infected with covid19
and the epidemic is doubling in size
every nine days
on that trend assuming nothing changed
there would be 12 million new cases a
day by christmas
the epidemic is still at its worst in
the north with one in 36 people in
yorkshire and the humber now infected
but it's growing fastest in the south
the r number in
every region is above two and in london
it may even be nudging three
at that rate the south will catch up
with the north within weeks
whether the policy that's that's
implemented is progressively done on a
regional level
or whether it's it's more of a uniform
policy the thing we absolutely have to
have
is really strong buying from people in
all the regions where the policy is in
effect so
if you're going to use most regional
interventions the sooner you put them on
then the less time they'll need to be in
place and the sooner
lower level you'll be at when you come
out much of europe has reported
record numbers in recent days france
which is about to go into another
month-long lockdown had more than 36 000
confirmed cases on wednesday
and even germany the country that did so
well back in the spring
reported almost 17 000 and is shutting
down
bars and restaurants the uk is not alone
in struggling
to reign in the virus the exponential
rise in cases will lead to a surge in
hospital admissions in two to three
weeks time
as some people become seriously ill
they've already risen by a third in just
the last week
according to new figures from public
health england but they have
much further to go it will be a busy
autumn for the nhs
thomas more sky news